welcome to an extended episode of the
what's what service count series
in this video i'm going to demonstrate a
few of the things that we talked about
in some of the previous episodes
if you haven't caught those yet check
them out in the description
without further ado let's see service
accounts in action
[Music]
for this first demonstration i'm going
to show you how to create a compute
instance with a user managed service
account attached to it
and how a user with access to this
instance is able to use that service
account
in this example in addition to the
project viewer role
my user account is granted the compute
admin role on the project so i can
create and manage compute instances i
also have the role service account user
but only for a service account called
bucket admin
and not the entire project the bucket
admin service account has a role storage
admin assigned to it that allows it to
create and manage gcs buckets
okay let's start by creating a compute
instance by going over here
compute engine create
if you scroll down here this is where
you'll
indicate what service account you want
to use for your compute instance so
let's pick one that i don't have any
access to
let's pick sql admin and hit create
and you'll see that this isn't going to
work because i have
no roles assigned to my user account
over the service account and there it
goes
if you hover over this little red circle
it says it right there that i need the
service account user role on that
service account so let's just delete
this
and create a new instance with the right
service account
so once again we're going to scroll down
here and this time i'm going to pick
the bucket admin service account which i
do have access to i am the service
account user for that
service account so give that a second
all it creates
boom there it is green check mark means
that the instance is running
so next i'm going to show you that i
don't have access
to create a bucket using gsutil down
here i'm going to
try to make a bucket
and this should fail
and yes access denied so i don't have
access to create a bucket but i do have
access to ssh
into this instance
and now that i'm in there i can show you
with gcloud auth list
that the credentialed account isn't me
it's the service account attached to the
vm
there it is bucket admin so if i'm
bucket admin that means i should be able
to create a bucket
even though i couldn't do that as myself
before so let's try that
gsutil make bucket
a new bucket
and there it is no error message and
that's because
i created a bucket as a service account
note that i only needed the service
account user role to attach the service
account to the instance
but to use a service account from the
compute instance i just needed to have
ssh access that's really important to
keep in mind for users that have access
to your vms
for this next demonstration i'm going to
generate a key and show you how i can
use it to act as a service account to
access resources
this time i'm going to be a user with
the viewer role on the project
and the service account key admin role
granted only on the service account
called
sql admin that service account has a
cloud sql admin role sign
so it's able to create new cloud sql
instances and
manage any that are already in the
project if you wanted to create a
service account key through the cloud
console here's how you do that
under i am in admin service accounts
and hit that menu right next to the
account that you want to create a key
for there should be a create key option
right there
but for this demonstration i'm going to
use the cloud shell so i'm going to
create a key down here
that's g cloud i am service accounts
keys create followed by a file name
and then we're going to indicate the im
account that we want to create a key for
so remember this will only work if you
have the service account key admin role
assigned
and since i don't have that role
assigned to me
project wide if i put a service account
that i don't have access to like
bucket admin it won't work
see permission denied so let's put in a
service account that i
do have that role assigned for
and that would be a sql admin
and that worked so now the private key
was saved to that key.json file i
indicated in the command
you can check the keys that already
exists with gcloud
im service accounts keys list
followed by the i am account flag
and the service account that you want to
see a list of keys for
the output for this is going to include
the key i just created as well
as a system manage key that was added
when the service account was created
so now that we have a key let's see what
i can do with that so first let me just
show you that i do not have
any roles or permissions that allow me
to create a cloud sql instance so
let's try to create one as myself
and this should fail yes
so i don't have that permission but my
service account does
so how do i use it gcloud auth
activate service account followed by
the service account name
and then indicate the key file
that was key.json
boom activated service account
credentials so to verify that
gcloud auth list will show that sql
admin
is the active account right now and that
means
now if i try to create another sql
instance
it should work
and success so remember the surface
account
key admin role was only used to create
the key
a user with as little as a project
viewer role will still be able to use
that key to act as a service account
so be sure to have a really secure way
of distributing that key
and a decent key rotation process in
place
this last demonstration is going to be
like the last one except i'm going to be
impersonating a service account without
keys
my user account will only have the
viewer role on the project
on the in policy of the service account
sql admin
i'm going to have the service account
token creator role and nothing else
let's see what i can do with that so for
this demonstration i'm just going to
delete the database instance that i
created in the last example
so i'll try to do that first as myself
so g
cloud sql instances delete
followed by the instance name
hit yes and there you go i'm not
authorized to make that request
but now let me run the same command
except this time i'm going to add the
impersonate service account flag
followed by the service account name
do i want to continue i'm gonna say yes
and as you can see something is
happening this time
and the cloud sql instance is deleted
and i was able to do that without having
any roles having to do with cloud sql
assigned to me
and without the use of any service
account keys all i had
was a service account token creator role
on that one service account's iam policy
the impersonate service account flag
works on any gcloud command
and is the most straightforward example
of how you can use the service account
token creator role
the role also lets users create
short-lived credentials
and generate service account access
tokens so they can send requests to the
google cloud rest api
as a service account well that's that
for what's what
what do you think of the series do you
have any other questions about service
accounts
feel free to let us know in the comments
below and to learn
more about service accounts visit
cloud.google.com
i am service accounts
thanks for watching and see you next
time
you